from George of the Jungle to the whale
Brendan Fraser had quite the career but
do you know exactly how he's become the
comeback King let's get into it can you
name Brendan's debut film if you guessed
1991's dogfight you'd be right he had a
pretty minor role there playing a
character who wasn't even deemed
important enough to be named seriously
the credits on dogfight simply list him
as sailor number one but he picked up
the ball quickly by the very next year
he'd already nabbed his first leading
role in School Ties I thought it was
also going to be my last one for all I
knew oh no worries Brendan that same
year he would also go on to star in and
Chino man for Brendan every role that he
landed back then felt like life and
death because those are the stakes of a
Young Person's ambition but his career
was only just beginning obvi
how many of you remember that theme song
George George of the Jungle strong yes
he can be that's right we're talking
about the 1997 Disney live action film
George of the Jungle George is the the
original babe in the woods or the role
that truly turned Brendan Fraser into a
household name it got mixed reviews from
critics but audiences loved it helping
it to bring in 170 million against a 55
million budget as a Tarzan spoof based
on the animated series from the 1960s
Brendan's wardrobe really wasn't much
more than a loincloth and he recalls how
he was waxed and starved of
carbohydrates for the role it even got
so bad that I could not remember my PIN
number apparently his brain was
misfiring so bad that it just wasn't
coming to him
but even this role was nothing compared
to what was coming if you thought George
in the jungle was big news the this next
one made him the star of his own
franchise The Mummy released in 1999 was
a massive hit pulling in a whopping
416.4 million against an 80 million
dollar budget it had a little bit of um
not danger per se but some risk taking
to it this role was a special kind of
challenge for Brendan who had to do his
own fighting stunts and even ride camels
across the Searing hot desert while
filming in Morocco will we survive still
as difficult as filming was Brendan says
I loved making that movie you could
really see his passion for the project
too considering he went on to star in
two of the movie sequels but if you want
to show your passion for our Channel you
don't need to ride a camel to do it just
click that subscribe button while we
move on to discussing a few of Brendan's
other beloved roles back in the early
2000s Brendan Fraser was like everywhere
he was cast in everything from the
Harold Ramey's comedy bedazzled in 2000
to 2003's Looney Tunes back in Action
his role in The Academy award-nominated
Gods and Monsters earned Brendan more
respect from film critics but he'd also
receive cameos in The Simpsons and King
of the Hill where's all my swanks he
became the first american-born actor to
be inducted into Canada's Walk of Fame
in 2006 but by then the roles had really
started to dry up and the movies he was
being offered really weren't that good I
mean take a look at his role in 2008's
Journey to the Center of the Earth so
what happened well this first blow took
place in 2003 when Brendan was touched
inappropriately by the former president
of the hfpa Philip Burke Brendan said
that he felt ill and like he was going
to cry he decided not to go public about
it at the time because he didn't want to
contend with how much that made him feel
or for it to become part of his
narrative so Brendan's reps asked Burke
for a written apology but Burke
responded with a week if I've done
anything that upset me Fraser it was not
intended after this Brendan noticed that
the roles really started to dry up for
him so much so that he actually wondered
if he had been blacklisted because of
the letter Brendan became incredibly
depressed after this even blaming
himself for what happened on top of the
depression Brendan had a few personal
issues to work through he'd always been
willing to perform whatever stunts he
needed to do but that was starting to
catch up with him while he was filming
for the third mummy movie in 2008. like
they said I was playing hurt he'd
receive injury after injury on set even
needing to get a laminectomy it was a
lot yeah it was a lot of fighting a lot
of fall down go boom several other
surgeries came in the following years
which really affected his ability to do
the action-packed roles he'd become
famous for around the time I made that
movie it was sort of a fundamental shift
in my Approach and that wasn't even the
end of it in 2007 Brendan divorced his
wife after nine years of marriage
ouch but his bad luck wouldn't last
forever in 20 16 Brendan gave his first
interview in years and it was a little
hard to watch Brendan just seemed so
depressed why did we not see Brendan in
that trailer even mentioning that he
felt and hold or boxed as an actor the
whole thing actually went sort of viral
and people felt so bad for him wondering
what had happened well as it turns out
Brendan had just lost his mother to
cancer days before that interview was
filmed not only that but he was
uncomfortable with the setup which left
him wondering damn this is the way it's
done now Brendan explained this in the
same 2018 interview with GQ where he
went public about his experience with
Philip Burke this interview also went
viral as it helped us all understand
what he'd been through after these
enlightening interviews the internet was
cheering to see Brendan again and it
wouldn't be long before we'd get our
wish Brendan lent his voice to the
character of Robot Man in Titans in 2018
even going on to reprise the role in
Doom Patrol some saw this as a sign of
his big return as fans on Tick Tock
started using the hashtag Renaissance
every time I hear that I want to look at
the ceiling oh look here's Rick
O'Connell oh look there's George of the
Jungle in 2021 it was announced that
he'd be playing playing the villain
Firefly in the upcoming Batgirl movie
but as excited as we were all to see it
the project would later be canceled in
2022 yet the Renaissance was only
getting started when you think about the
Renaissance the first movie that
probably comes to mind is the whale this
was actually his first leading role
since 2013. Brendan was cast after
director Darren Aronofsky had spent 10
years looking for the perfect leading
man but he knew Brendan could fill that
role after seeing him in only one
trailer to be honest I had never really
seen any of his films and what convinced
Darren he'd be right for the role I
think once a movie star always a movie
star apparently Darren hadn't even heard
about the Renaissance which just goes to
show how right the time was for
Brendan's return you can probably
already imagine how the internet
responded too everybody loved to see
Brendan back and we aren't just talking
about the internet either when the whale
premiered at the Venice International
Film Festival he received a six minute
long standing ovation that reduced him
to tears and not only that but Brendan
received his first Oscar nom for best
actor in the whale he was given the
tribute award from the Toronto
International Film Festival that's a
wonderful affirmation
it's new to me and although he'd also
received a best actor Nom from the
Golden Globes he decided not to attend
because of their association with the
hfpa joking my mother didn't raise a
hypocrite but for all the praise
Brendan's been receiving for the whale
he's tried to stay humble I'll take
nothing for granted knowing how
far-reaching this journey has been and
what a journey it's been Brendan he's
definitely come a long way from
forgetting his pin number what would you
say is your favorite Brendan Fraser
movie there's so many good ones to
choose from but we're hoping you can
give us your pick down in the comments
section and we're coming for you if it's
Journey to the Center of the Earth
foreign